good morning believe nation today's
message is get talented players over to
you Ryan Coogler a college coach once
said you know 95 percent of coaching
college football is recruiting you know
if you were to get talented players a
lot of your work is done it's done for
yourself you know if the same thing goes
for directing when you cast the right
actors you know you find talented actors
that I thought that generally great
people you know what I mean to spend
time with me being around a lot of your
work is done for yourself so what do you
think I think about when I'm teaching a
class at Rana dance salsa I usually have
an assistant up front and I could
honestly say all of them that are
assisting me up front are really really
talented people they're talented in a
sense that not only that they're
wonderful dancers which is actually very
important but they're very positive they
have the family vibe they actually
really really want to help the students
I think about one of them he really
connects with the students and he
connects with the students in from a
very empathetic place which actually
increases the value that the students
are getting so I find that so important
to get the right team I wouldn't be able
to do what I do teaching the lesson if I
did not have my assistant up front with
me yeah I think it's important for any
big project that you have to understand
that you can't do it alone if you want
to go fast you do it by yourself but if
you want to go far you have to do it
with the team and so I think it's really
important for all you guys to think
about even if it's somebody part-time
even if somebody who you're just pinging
advice for that you start thinking of
how you can involve others in your
mission
I love how Lilly extended the definition
of talent to involve their values and
not just look at somebody on paper and
say yes this person's a good salsa
dancer yes this person's a good
programmer good graphic designer or
whatever not just the skills because you
need their values as well you need to
have somebody who loves the mission who
you can get along with and work with and
go you're getting their hearts and soul
and not just their brain and so I love
the extension of what talent is defined
as for when you're going out finding
talented players you want the heart and
the ability so the question of the day
today is how do you define talent like
that leaving the comments below we're
gonna join in the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
have an amazing day we believe in you we
hope you continue believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is and we'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event spread though